so petey i just want you to read
this part right here that i have circled
okay all right
right am i going to get credit for this
there is no credit just read the lines
you're not going to put this on stop
i'm counting down and five four three
two
what button do i press and start
recording oh my god petey
it's already on oh
no
can you please just read the paper
the following documents the events
surrounded by a missing person's
investigation this investigation was
conducted by
family friends a bitch-ass police
department oh i hate the police i really
do
i told you they tried to tell me i can't
bring my raccoon to the dog park petey
stop talking go
thanks go
just like the police whatever
sorry about that that's my cousin petey
he agreed to let me stay here with him
in la while i conduct my
investigation as long as i let him help
me out from time to time but
okay here we go the following
documents the events surrounded by a
missing person's investigation
this investigation was conducted by
family friends
a bitch-ass police department and myself
rose cranberry who is not a journalist
by any means this is
looking for latoya
she was so sweet kind of a bird but so
sweet i told her black ass to never
leave atlanta
i heard cali be on that [ __ ] i mean
yeah we went to prom together but we
haven't talked in years
i thought she been dead i don't think
she did
she shouldn't be packing them you know
they ain't looking
nobody cares when our girls go missing
see that's why i don't go to red lobster
no one ever goes missing from chile
[Music]
remotes bobby pins socks
a favorite v-neck all replaceable things
that we
tend to fret over when they are lost or
simply misplaced
but when it comes to missing black girls
it's a topic often overlooked
no one checks the crevices of the couch
behind the dryer
the junk drawer it seems as though these
missing black girls are just
forgotten and it's nothing new
this has been an issue for years i think
about it
we still haven't found the original dark
skin clear from my wife and kids
but that's another podcast this podcast
is about 26 year old latoya thompson
hey rose you seen my texas toast
[Music]
for the last nine years i've proudly
served as the certified theft specialist
and chief investigative officer
for a burlington coat factory back in
atlanta georgia
although it's just called burlington now
anyway my job has always required me to
have a very
keen sense of detail after years of
monitoring both entrance
and exit doors screening hardcore
criminals
reviewing top secret security footage
and binging law and order repeats
there's not much that can get past me
i pay attention to things i
notice things
see at burlington we have an array of
customers
but we also have our committed regulars
who frequent the store on a weekly basis
one of those people was glinda thompson
glinda typically came in once a week to
browse linens and
stock up on scenic candles often times
she'd be accompanied by her 26 year old
daughter
latoya they were both so friendly
and always smiling and made sure to
greet me
we even spoke from time to time i
remember the day glinda came in alone
and she told me that latoya had moved to
los angeles to be a star
which came as no surprise to me because
i'd often see latoya twerking for the
store cameras
[Music]
but after a few weeks i noticed
something had changed with glinda
she stopped greeting me her linen
selection got
lazy her smile had completely
faded it looked as though something was
weighing on her something heavy
so i approached her with a few questions
all i really know is that she moved in
with a girl named tasha
said she signed up for some overpriced
acting class taught by a renowned actor
but i couldn't even find him on google
she started fooling with some guy named
rufus
and said he was on his way to being one
of those influencers
she mentioned something about his teeth
um
they're loose or dead maybe both
i knew we should never let her leave
atlanta
glenda went on to tell me she hadn't
heard from latoya in quite some time
she was officially announced as missing
and had been since july 23rd
the last place she'd been seen was at a
red lobster in inglewood california
that's when rose
you want some texture no petey damn
can't you see i'm
i'm recording
sorry like i was saying that's when i
knew i had to help
glinda explained to me that latoya was
missing
and to no surprise no one seemed to care
i felt with all my experience in
resolving shoplifting cases
catching petty criminals and assessing
missing items
it was a chance for me to step up
it was time for me to do something more
important than loss prevention
lost girls prevention but just the black
ones
the white ones are fine that's when i
decided to pursue my
own investigation make my way to los
angeles and start this podcast
[Music]
i've also been told that i have a good
radio voice i've occasionally been asked
to make the intercom announcements in
the department store
leanne you're needed at the register
leanne need it at the register
biscuits cheddar bay biscuits
a convenient and delicious luxury for
many but for latoya
it might have been the bite between life
and death
who's responsible did anyone see this
coming
could anyone have stopped it is latoya
just missing or was she
murdered i was determined to find out
when i arrived in l.a i decided to start
my investigation
jehovah witness style going door to door
in latoya's neighborhood
[Applause]
have you seen this girl nah have you
no that's why i was at okay
hi have you done told y'all
[ __ ] i ain't selling my house
[Music]
um hi does this girl
look familiar to you oh
[ __ ] ain't that the original little
sister for my wife and kids
a dark skinned one i'm glad she good
no no that was not the original sister
from
my wife and kids it was
latoya after spending hours
checking all the low-income apartments
in the inglewood area
i was finally able to track down where
latoya lived
for a small exchange fee which i won't
elaborate
on the landlord gave me both latoya
and her roommate tasha's contact info
of course i called latoya to no avail
we're sorry the customer you are trying
to reach
is currently unavailable please hang up
and try again
i then doubt tasha hoping to get an
answer
you've reached tasha i ain't here so you
know what to do
leave it hi tasha
this is rose cranberry i'm calling about
your roommate latoya thompson
please call me back as soon as you can
as i'm trying to gather some information
on her acting coach
or the friend with the dead teeth hope
to hear from you soon
thanks much like the current state of my
hair
i had hit another dead end so far i was
getting nowhere
i knew something was up when she came in
with the white boy
her acting coach they came for the
cheddar biscuits after class
the voices you just heard are that of
two red lobster employees
travis and stacy who claim to have seen
latoya last
i was able to sit down with them both
it was weird because you know white
people don't ever go to the inglewood
red lobster they always complain the
music too loud
yeah unless they tourist and trying to
experience the hood
they usually go to the one in torrance
plus we
always out of salmon they hate that
i see so tell me what you saw that day
well they was just sitting at the bar
like they always do
so this was a regular thing yup they
came in like once a week
but this time he was looking suspicious
and why is that
he was wearing a hoodie and he was
drinking a sprite with no ice
that's serial killer [ __ ] i see
well i was told latoya had a boyfriend
do you think it's safe to say that she
was having an affair with this guy
man i ain't no damn snitch but i
definitely think he hit
ain't nobody just gonna buy you biscuits
without some booty
and she always looked hella happy yeah
but this time he rushed out all quick
i think he left right when the biscuits
came so she was just sitting there alone
with a basket full of biscuits looking
all inspired and [ __ ]
and how long would you say latoya sat
there before she left
i don't know maybe like 20 minutes she
was gone when i came back for my break
i went to carl's jr
after learning this tasty tidbit i knew
it was time for me to have a talk with
this cheddar bae
it took a while for me to get in touch
with him as he was on tour
doing a monologue series in conjunction
with reese witherspoon in ice cube
i met latoya in the acting class i teach
we once reenacted a scene from the
players club together
she was not a good actor but she was
very beautiful and had the biggest heart
would you say you two were dating well
yeah
we love each other we had a pretty deep
connection
i've always had an appreciation for
colored women like latoya
colored she was special i left my wife
for her
i'm sorry you're married well not
anymore
okay um tell me about your weekly red
lobster dates
well one day after class she asked me to
give her some notes on her voice
inflections
you know like i never said he owed me
money versus i never said he owed me
money
so i agreed to help her out she
suggested red lobster since it was near
her house
that just became our go-to spot
it was really cool to see the area she
lived it was very lively
i had never been to the red lobster on
century
y'all stay out my salmon
[Music]
i've always gone to the one on torrance
can you tell me exactly what happened at
this
july 23rd lunch i went but
i couldn't stay long i had to miss lunch
for a big
audition but it was worth it
i got a call back for the simi valley
junior college repertory theaters
production of
sons of anarchy the musical
i did not get the part but now they know
me
congratulations thanks she was really
intrigued by my success
she just kept saying wait and you'll see
someday i'll be a part of your world
anyway i've been looking forward to but
a new black girl just enrolled in the
class
so it's fine if you can't find her we
still meet our diversity quota
as nice as it would have been to be able
to blame the white man
cheddar base story checked out i spoke
to the dean of the semi valley junior
college repertory theater
and cheddar bay did indeed audition that
day
and he did not get the part but i knew
there was more to this
did latoya have a secret was she hiding
something
i knew there was only one person who
would have these answers
the person closest to latoya her
roommate
tasha who had finally returned my call
hey rose my bad i'm just not calling you
back i was swatching boopsie on
instagram loving you know lost track of
time
i'd be so busy but i'm free to come talk
to you tomorrow
i honestly feel like it's her boyfriend
he's a suspect
and ain't nobody questioning that [ __ ]
you can text me the time and address and
i
will be there you ain't gonna call me
back i was happy to finally hear from
tasha
knowing her information could
potentially bring us one step
closer to finding latoya
tasha can you explain your relationship
with latoya
we've been roommates ever since she
moved to l.a we became friends
after we met at bill bellamy's house it
was taco tuesday
how close are you guys she would tell me
everything
and she was always there when i needed
somebody to talk to
i know latoya had a boyfriend
can you tell me about that relationship
um well in the beginning everything was
great
she told me how special he made her feel
he would give her
all of his attention he would never
check his phone when they were together
she never even heard it vibrate she said
he always kept it face down
out of respect for her i was happy for
her and i couldn't wait to find me a man
to treat me the same way
when do you think such a beautiful
relationship took a turn
it was something about social media he
would make her delete any video where
you could hear his voice
or see his arm and what was the last
thing she said about him
well she told me her and her boyfriend
were having problems they was
always arguing did you see anything that
would make you think
he was a suspect well
this particular day i was in my car i
looked out the window
and i was like nah that don't look right
it looked dangerous
i know he knows something did he do it
you do
know cheddar bae was the last person she
was with before she went
missing right yeah i know about that
white boy but i
still think it's rufus a [ __ ] with
deceased teeth
is always a suspect
it's it it's your life
i really miss my friend i want to help
look i do
but my tags on my car they expire you
know
your only hope rose please
we will find her
i knew the only way i could solve this
case was to talk to this
boyfriend rufus and like i said before
i've seen enough law in order to know
there's always a suspicious
boyfriend boyfriend
whoa whoa whoa chill chill y'all gotta
chill with that she said that
look i mean we were talking all right
did i hit
yeah i hit but i didn't kill her though
i mean i killed the [ __ ] but
but uh my condolences to her moms and
pops though
i don't know where she at man i sat down
with tasha
she always run in her mouth she told me
you and latoya had conflicts over social
media
can you expand on that man i don't even
have a social media account bruh
real peace stay off the scene always ten
toes hardly ever seen
you understand what i'm saying actually
i don't you know what kills me
what kills you rufus her claiming that i
was her boyfriend
like she deserved to be wifed she
couldn't even support her [ __ ] dreams
man
she wanted me to play ti and practice
that give me my chain back scene
from atl for her acting class right
bro i hate that movie and she ain't
lauren london either
i tell you that much why would i care
about that
if she can't post some [ __ ] to help me
make some money does that make any sense
all right does that sound like somebody
i would make my girl
what did you want her to post i just
wanted her to ask her followers
who got chase cash app or venmo
y'all got cash out y'all got vmware
that's it you know i was gonna put some
money in the account and take a little
bit off the top
that is a crime but i see that you're
upset
is that what you were arguing about at
the mall i'm not upset all right don't
try to paint that picture
that day i was slipping super slipping
i mean we were pulling up to the mall
she grabbed my phone and it was unlocked
okay and then she seen that my alerts
was off and she saw
my work hitting me up about a bunch of
different things
work so you were cheating
look this ain't about me that was the
last time i seen her missing ass
period and i know about the acting coach
too yeah
y'all need to be going to check him find
out some [ __ ] about him
always focused on the black man rufus
where were you the night she went
missing i was recording a live podcast
for all my hustlers out there okay the
[ __ ] was live
yeah super lit swoop you can check it
out too on onthecomeup.net
all right they got hella views hella
views like
19 20 19 or 20
000 million nah
just 19 or 20
to to be exact but the link is still
up though if y'all want to go check it
out
talking to rufus was well a headache
but he did make me realize something
maybe i wasn't looking hard enough maybe
there was
something i was missing then it hit me
rufus pronounced
roof us roof
latoya was raised under her parents
roof how could i have missed that
this development meant it was time to
talk to glenda and brian
for more of latoya's origin story maybe
they knew something more
although they were hesitant about
speaking with me
and hate airplanes i was finally able to
convince them to come out to la for a
sit down
i offered glinda a burlington gift card
and she was able to clear their schedule
immediately
our latoya has always had big dreams of
living in los angeles
yeah yeah she's always wanted to be a
star ever since she was a little girl
but we told her she was already a star
in our eyes
she had already accomplished so much she
starred as an extra in a rack room shoes
commercial a few years ago
um i think it was a wreck room it was it
was rack room
yeah you can see my baby's ankle real
clear i know my baby's ankle
and after that she became an ambassador
for blue magic hair grease
even spoke on a panel about it oh that
that's big exactly that's what i'm
talking about
i mean my baby ain't never been one to
just disappear on us she told us
everything even about that raggedy ass
boy um rufus
i don't know how she got involved with
them brian taught latoya at a young age
to
never get involved with a man who only
owns one
towel man i sure did i'm saying i used
to be that [ __ ] so i know
is there anything specific latoya
mentioned
about rufus to make you so certain he
was involved in her disappearance
she told me that one time rufus asked
her to marry him right quick
so he could be added to her dental
insurance she said no and he didn't like
that
then she said he got upset and
threatened to throw chicken nuggets at
her
oh no he did it i know it in my heart he
did it
whoa whoa whoa baby now come on come on
we don't know that okay we don't know
that for sure we don't know that
all we can do is have faith and and and
pray look i know my baby's out there
somewhere and we're not gonna give up
if anybody anybody has any information
at all please don't hesitate to come
forward
any little thing will help any snapchat
photos um
any instagrams whatever you got on that
little [ __ ]
i don't trust his ass
it was clear to me that no one seemed to
trust a rufus's ass
and it was starting to feel like i was
hitting a wall
travis and stacy both saw gabe the
cheddar bay
leave red lobster before latoya gabe's
audition for sons of anarchy the musical
checks out tasha's tags are definitely
expired
and there's nothing pointing in her
direction as a suspect
i did however follow up on rufus's
podcast alibi
and he was telling the truth except
about
one little thing
there were only 14 views on that podcast
not nearly 19 or 20.
but unfortunately a sorry podcast
does it make you a murderer
rose you're recording yes pity what
my sports set is missing seen it no i
haven't i haven't seen it latoya's still
missing too
still oh damn
it was time i tried my luck with a
higher authority
the inner city police department i met
with the lead detective on the case
to try and get some answers
[Music]
i don't know what to tell you we have
put as many resources as we can
towards finding toyota we put her photo
up
all around the city we've held several
press conferences
i went out and attended one of these
press conferences
i want to assure the good people of los
angeles that we are doing everything
in our power to ensure the safe return
of this lost
toyota sir again this is the case about
the missing african-american girl latoya
thompson not a missing vehicle
no further comment at this time
i wanted to catch up with this reporter
as she seemed to be
just as dedicated to this case as i was
unfortunately by the time the press
conference ended
she too had been reported missing
i can't find everyone i just can't i i'm
tired i
i can't
after running out of ideas i knew there
was
one last place i could turn a place that
was sure to have a black woman's best
interest at heart
i decided to go to a local inglewood
hair salon
where latoya frequented and honestly
i needed a trim to no surprise
the girl who cuts hair wasn't available
because she too
had gone missing very inconvenient for
me
but anyway
i got the salon up to speed on the case
i gave them a rundown of all the
evidence and interviews i've collected
so far
y'all know who did it right they're
white man
you know that crazy just like autumn
lifetime movie
but his story checks out i called the
college about his audition
did the person who answered the phone
sound white maybe
i'm i'm not sure um
there it is you can't trust the white
man
even in this story check out you know
they all work together
that girl is dead no no no it was rufus
you sound like just the rest of these
bum ass la dudes
girl hire you a private investigator to
follow rufus
i can give you the number to one now
he's been following both of my [ __ ]
for a week
i don't think that will be necessary
well i think she's still alive
what you need to do is set up your own
tip line those police don't care
it's our job to find her before she
winds up under the sea or
wants a wig chart like the rest of them
she was right we do have to find her
the last thing we need is latoya's face
plastered on a wig chart in a rundown
beauty supply store
we can't give up i won't let us
so i took her advice and started a tip
line
of my own i made a facebook page too
where all black gossip lives and after
just two weeks
the calls were rolling in
thank you for calling she lost where our
number one priority
is bringing latoya home please leave
your name
number and any information you may have
after
the beep hello
my name is crystal and i think i just
saw
latoya at the swing stop in inglewood
i'm here waiting for my garlic wing and
this [ __ ] with a dead
tooth try to talk to me after i gave him
my number
i seen him go to his car and it was a
girl in the passenger seat
i couldn't tell what she looked like but
i remember him from your facebook ads
that's all the info i got so do not
call me back
[Music]
this is jessica i just seen your flyer
outside the bowling alley
i don't know who latoya is but can you
put flowers up with me
i want [ __ ] looking for me too
hey rose petey from downstairs your
cousin
no latoya but i found my sports set you
wouldn't believe where
yo this mic i think i have some info
that can help you find this latoya chick
is there a reward though if so call me
back
after going through these voicemails
i decided to give mike a call back
after i lied and told him there was a
reward
he finally provided me with some key
information
before i say [ __ ] i need that reward
asap
i'ma text you my paypal info no problem
i'll have my assistant petey handle it
cool
okay so look i was taking my side piece
on a day down in long beach
it's safe out there so i knew nobody was
gonna see me it was the same night you
said old girl went missing
anyway we were walking up past the docks
shorty i was with had never seen docs
before so she was all like oh
dogs that's when i saw latisha latoya
whatever but there she would
thanks to mike's alertness and more
importantly
his infidelity he was able to provide
some
very helpful tips we're now
one step closer to finding our beloved
latoya updates coming soon
until then thanks for listening i'm
rose cranberry and i'll see you on the
next installment of
looking for latoya
looking for latoya is a rose cranberry
production
created hosted produced and
edited by me rose cranberry
if you have questions comments or any
further information
please leave me a message i'd like to
thank my burlington coat factory family
red lobster the inglewood hair salon and
the family and friends of latoya
thompson
for their participation in this
investigation
oh and of course my cousin petey
for his um help and accommodations
but i purposely did not mention the
police
with their [ __ ] asses
[Music]
thank you for listening to looking for
latoya we came up with the idea for this
series in the insecure writers room as a
satirical way to highlight the plight of
missing black women
but that's not a joke and that's why
radio tenderfoot and hbo
are proud to support the black and
missing foundation
the black and missing foundation is a
non-profit organization
founded in 2008 by natalie wilson and
derricka wilson
to help bring awareness to an invisible
group our missing
their mission is to bring awareness to
the hundreds of thousands of missing
brown and black men women and children
to search for those missing and to
educate our community on personal safety
since its inception the black and
missing foundation has supported and
provided access to resources for
thousands of families searching for
missing loved ones
their efforts have helped locate more
than 300 missing persons
but with your support so many more can
return home
let's all the media law enforcement and
the community
do our part to help us find us
visit bamfi.org
to join the movement to hashtag help us
find
us it only takes one person to come
forward with information to help solve
the case
you